my name is Amber l cardi Oh glamour ooh
and I have an identity that you might
categorize as intersectional I'm British
Iraqi gay non-binary and also identify
as Muslim and reading about quantum
physics has really helped me understand
my queer identity
[Music]
quantum physics is a beautiful strange
and glorious sect of physics that looks
up as subatomic particles that govern
our world so inside the neutrons
electrons and the protons are looking at
the quarks leptons bosons and the Higgs
whereas classical Newtonian physics is
obsessed with the universal formula that
govern our reality it's so fixed on
resolute answers quantum physics reveals
that there is no fixed reality and it's
full of beautiful contradictions we can
now observe that the same subatomic
particle can be in many places at the
same time so if we fire an electron
through a wall with two holes for
instance we should be able to see that
it goes through one or the other but on
a quantum level when you observe what's
going on we seem that the same particle
is actually going through both holes at
the same time multiple versions of the
same event are happening all at the same
time what's so remarkable about quantum
physics is the fact that what's
happening on a subatomic level
contradicts what we're actually seeing
happening in reality it shows us that
reality is itself a construct and what's
going on internally on a subatomic level
belies what we're actually observing
quantum physics to Newtonian physics is
to me what queer theory is to
heteronormativity I looking for
normative constructs of society
male/female of gender of race
categorizing everything in a kind of
neat rigid way I am very comforted by
this as a queer person with no real
fixed identity gives me immense hope
that there's this model of the world
this real physical philosophical model
which shows us that reality is just a
set of contradictions with no real fixed
foundation it is in this model of
space-time as a series of entanglements
that I'm able to piece together all the
fragmented sex of my identity being able
to identify as British and Iraqi as
queer a Muslim as someone of many
genders and potentially no genders at
all
you